La última carta antes de perder la
mayoría en la cámara de representantes
el comité de medios y arbitrios de la
cámara baja estadounidense publicó las
declaraciones de los impuestos del
expresidente Donald Trump de 2015 a 2020
pese a la larga batalla legal del
republicano para impedir que vieran la
luz la comisión publicó miles de páginas
de los documentos Fiscales que podrían
ser investigados por periodistas y
expertos independientes un presidente no
es un contribuyente ordinario tiene
poder e influencia A diferencia de
cualquier otro estadounidense y un gran
poder conlleva una responsabilidad aún
mayor análisis preliminares mostraron
que el Trump declaró grandes pérdidas en
sus negocios para pagar casi nada en
impuestos durante años llegando a no
pagar en absoluto en 2020 antes de su
salida de la presidencia el comité
demócrata detrás de la publicación No
solo Busca responsabilizar a Trump sino
también al servicio de impuestos interno
al que señalan de no auditar
correctamente al expresidente Trump
rompió con el presidente al convertirse
en el primer aspirante a la casa blanca
y luego presidente en mantener sus decla
en las sombras sirven para los
demócratas la publicación es cuestión de
transparencia los republicanos alegan un
peligroso precedente al erosionar la
privacidad fiscal de los ciudadanos el
republicano le restó importancia a la
publicación
aunque estas declaraciones de impuestos
contienen relativamente poca información
y no información que casi cualquiera
puede entender son extremadamente
complejas el comportamiento de los
demócratas radicales es una vergüenza
para el congreso de Estados Unidos
en septiembre de 2020 el New York Times
publicó en exclusiva un reporte
demostrando que Trump no pago impuestos
sobre la renta en diez de los 15 años
anteriores a su llegada a la casa blanca
la revelaciones suponen un nuevo golpe
al ex mandatario que busca regresar a la
Casa Blanca en 2024